how's it going bros my name is it's a
boy Oh
welcome to three free game soup it's
it's the show where we play a bunch of
games that are not Chitti starting off
with the reason you clicked on this
video - fist bro fist simulator finally
okay so how does is a okay so it's like
a simulator game but with bro fisting oh
oh oh you know take it can we take a
break I want to talk about something
serious so if you would fist someone I'm
not saying you have to do it but
wouldn't you kind of make this kind of
hand like cuz this hand makes this hand
and I'm like that doesn't that doesn't
make any sense also has a lot of hair on
it I would try and go in like this sorry
that got very weird fast I didn't
realize or you could go like this or
like this
that's a good one let's begin oh [__]
yeah bro yeah so I don't know what the
games fit oh my [__] fingers okay I
still got pinky hmm oh [__] come on
pinky there's paint oh there goes pinky
what is the point of the game what the
[__] was that
what does [__] is that [__] okay alright
pound me Brian that's said yeah that's
right shut now [__] I never thought this
thing would be so different
I said it before tonight let's keep the
thumb ax oh yeah buddy
just [__] rock it up okay so when we
when we fist
I have to unfix my hand it's like you
know oh I hate when people do that it's
the worst okay I'm getting points I got
it now boom
I gotta do different oh [__] I call this
one the thumbs up [__]
ah it's your finger bruh ah how hard can
you fit someone for that to happen I am
now terrified you know when I go to
convention everyone wants to brofist and
after a while my hand just starts to
hurt and then they like brofist and I'm
just like can we not it hurts
are we okay I gotta get a decent score
at this [__] I am the pro Lord after all
to to hike doing good damn it damn it
how does that even make any [__]
sense okay I don't think we're gonna get
any more entertainment value out of this
game so let's move on to the next one
it's called forklift simulator man oh
god what is this Unreal Engine the [__]
is this oh my god oh my god okay awesome
okay can I have my hands back no I can't
okay so as you can tell the general
theme between these games are fisting
okay what the [__] am i playing oh god
he quenches for it
I assume I have to go to the other side
go damn it
never enjoyed fisting this much in my
entire life you think I can make it you
think I could do it yeah fish big fish
ding fish stick hell yeah [__] a
puzzle game about fisting what a genius
idea
I love the sound effect that they added
it really does sound like something is
going in somewhere that's all I'm gonna
say about that all right I feel like
this this game can be used in schools to
teach children how to figure out how to
solve puzzles yeah come here buddy
yeah that's right that's right no oh my
helmet this is a block pit Varla no stop
fisting everything don't swear to God
oh my god oh my god I gotta climb more
yeah the puzzles are very easy [__]
damn it okay I did it
oh ah okay so that was a fisting
simulator oh boy that's a good one
let's move on to the final game cold
absorbed what how the [__] do I play
this wait no wait this is not a fisting
game this is a footing game oh here we
go
Isis Jet Set Radio future
why would you why would you make this
okay so here we go the final gate it's
called
fist to the face and it doesn't work
okay final game all right listen up this
is the final game no more [__] no
more haha fisting can also be brofist
ha ha hilarious this is a game about
causing a scene oh that's a good sound
effect I'm gonna oh you got me right in
the dick and you know fist
Shaima holy [__] my fists are [__]
huge oh it's like I won one punch click
or whatever Oh [__] you suck you suck
even more he's so hot
please have my kids now imagine him bro
fisting him that'd be dope alright well
this game is so much fun that I can
hardly contain myself so I'm just gonna
do the outro while I play this game so
thank you very much for watching leave a
like if you enjoyed this video which of
course you did don't be don't be a liar
wow he got me right there you're
distracting me this doesn't matter
Oh Kevin thank you so much and I'll see
you brush in the next video
oh my god there's so much herring this
brofist
what is going on
you